[Música]
todo empezó en 2012 porque si se
recuerdan en el 2008 hubo una tragedia
que un joven llamaba
freddy villanueva
hubo un accidente con la policía y él
fue engañado murió por balas de la
policía así que 2013 era los cinco años
de este evento y como fotoperiodista a
mí me toca siempre trabajar con con
revistas con periódicos así que yo sé
que ellos se van a hacer algo sobre los
cinco años de la muerte de este joven y
la idea era bueno me parece que siempre
podemos leer la misma cosa sobre
montreal norte sobre los que las
pandillas sobre las drogas y la
violencia y los problemas los problemas
así que pero cuál sería otra manera de
presentar al barrio y qué piensa la
gente que vive adentro del barrio de su
de su barrio así que me fue hacer muchas
entrevistas y de éste empecé a trabajar
sobre montreal norte
primero hasta 2015 sólo tomando fotos de
eventos culturales y social y luego en
2018 empecé un otro capítulo de este
proyecto que estoy presentando en el
décimo aniversario finalmente de la
muerte de freddy villanueva de alguna
manera se cumplían diez años sí
pero fue casi de casualidad porque
después de trabajar 23 años sobre
montreal nortel a este punto para
empezar que era la muerte de freddy casi
desapareció porque yo después me fui me
interesé en la gente del barrio en el
barrio mismo en su historia
justamente esta parte de la exposición
se habla de la historia de un pueblo
chiquito que en menos de 50 años pasó de
mil habitantes a 100.000 y que ha
cambiado obviamente en la vida ha
cambiado muchísimo en estos 50 años y de
hecho leía yo por ahí en su en la
información que nos envió sobre la sobre
la exposición que montreal norte hasta
hace poco era una zona en la que se
sembraba se cultivaba comida pues
cultivos de alimentación y ahora es una
zona muy poblada hay mucha gente ahí y
hay muchos inmigrantes también de varios
orígenes hay muchos latinoamericanos
haitianos también que como podríamos
describir a la gente que viven fuera de
fuera de canadá este barrio que es uno
de los más multicultural es uno de los
más interculturales también porque las
las diferentes culturas están en
comunicación constante y en contacto
como los podemos describir físicamente
si la gente no puede verlo
ahora vamos a la imagen como lo podemos
imaginar es un barrio que ahora está muy
residencial así hay muchas casas muchos
motores pero pequeñas torres de para
vivir también
es si es sumamente como
un urbano con avenidas así grandes casi
autopistas adentro de la ciudad y claro
como ya he dicho muchos inmigrantes
vienen vienen aquí
y a mí es un barrio también que me toca
físicamente porque hay
tres fronteras que están así muy física
porque hay el río de la guerrilla de
freddy que es al norte hay también el
tren que es el sur y hay una autopista y
un chiquito río que está al lateral
sting así que es casi todo cerrado sólo
te puedes salir por la avenida san
miguel en granjas a michelle así que
también le da este por eso la gente
siempre me ha dicho aquí es como un
pueblo toda la gente se conoce y tenemos
este chico digamos el francés rico
como diríamos en español tejidos juntos
la gente es es un tejido social muy
apretadito pues y así que para mí este
hecho que hay fronteras físicas bien
bien definidas
me imagino que participa también a dar
este
y uno de los aspectos toda usted
mencionando es la historia del barrio
cómo ha cambiado y una de las cosas que
usted quiso hacer con este proyecto es
presentar fotos antiguas fotos de los
archivos a los a la gente que vive hoy
en el barrio para que las recrearán
háblenos de esta parte del proyecto que
parece muy interesante como lo ha
mencionado el hecho que hoy
son casi 50 por ciento de inmigrantes de
segunda generación de inmigrantes que
viven aquí esta gente ha vivido una
experiencia completamente diferente y
completamente distinta de la gente que
vive en este barrio desde 50 60 70 años
pero los dos a mí me parece tienen así
una identificación de identidad muy
fuerte con montreal nar de una un
orgullo casi de decir que vienen de este
barrio y así es muy interesante que con
diferente experiencia puede tener el
mismo sentimiento así cuál es la lectura
de los habitantes de hoy de
estos eventos de la historia así es una
conversación a través de fotos y a
través de la historia en el tiempo claro
y lo que es interesante es ver
justamente fotos de archivos y entonces
ir a ver el mismo lugar en el mismo en
la misma situación pero con personas
distintas recreadas estas fotografías
entonces vamos a mostrarle a nuestros
oyentes algunas de las imágenes
contrastando estas dos épocas digamos
para ver cómo evoluciono de alguna
manera es decir evolucionó mucho en la
región pero también puede ser lo puede
recrear puede seguir siendo la misma
región finalmente no cambio tanto cuando
uno ve esas fotos pueden ser re creadas
tan fácilmente
si es que
hay también parte de esos que las
situaciones quizás hoy pueden pueden
existir con nuevas formas por ejemplo
hay una una foto que es dos cazador que
tienen así una
un pájaro como un águila o algo así más
chiquito y así con las las escopetas muy
orgulloso y le enseña las fotos a los
jóvenes se vieron en dicho pero a
nosotros cazar no nos habla pero se
exhibían el tener un trofeo nos habla
así que vamos a traer el trofeo de
hockey y vamos a usar los los palos de
los palos de hockey vamos a ver crear la
foto adaptada a nuestro mundo moderno es
en realidad de hoy y también se puede
ver por las fotos como la demografía
como las orígenes de la gente ha
cambiado que éramos en las 50 50 con
mayoría de gente bueno digamos blancos
quebequense y francés exacto y que desde
este tiempo la demografía y la
inmigración ha cambiado completamente la
imagen del país así que hoy por estas
fotos son
son jóvenes adultos por estas fotos y
puedes venir quizás de américa latina de
áfrica de haiti del magreb o de de china
pueden ser que sean inmigrantes o hijos
o nietos de inmigrantes y hay una
variedad que es también de casualidad
porque yo no era buscando algún tipo de
persona pero que si vieras a las fotos
si las gracias vale bien gracias
[Música]